first of all
pimping got into me i didn't get in the
pimping
the sauce really chose me and that's
just how i go
being back from the bay when you're
shining you look good you handsome
you're not white somebody gonna come pay
you
somebody it's a [ __ ] out there that i
want to pay you she can't wait
so did you have like a bottom [ __ ] yeah
i did
that was like your man she was solid too
honestly i just don't have
the i don't care it's hard
i really don't care and it's it was hard
to
go through the motions of pimping
because you got to respect the game
and that's something not to be played
with because it don't change it's
forever though those rules are written
in stone
and you got to respect that and i knew
that because i didn't want to come in
disrespectful but at the same time
i had to consider like do i care enough
to respect it if i'm in it and i don't
because i'm a scammer so like i don't
want to call you if i just knocked your
business she paid me defeat
and now she want to come up under me i
don't care to call you and respect the
game